Auf gehts, wizard grind im kreis
easy, easy exp easy life
erst mal das game starten, hallo brick
game starten please
wie mich discord einfach, wie discord einfach gestartet ist beim anmelden und mich den channel
eingeloggt hat wtf, was ist discord, was ist wenn ich das nicht will, null
so sieht man das game jetzt ja mal, perfekt so muss es sein, ich glaube der chat der kann
noch ein stückchen höher, so ein ganz kleines bisschen, wieder overwatch de installiert,
oh habe ich das game noch auf overwatch stehen, ach nee, jetzt hast du mich aber geschockt
hier, nein ich habe overwatch nicht de installiert aber ich werde nicht spielen in nächster
zeit, wobei wann geht denn season 8 los, wann geht denn season 8 los, habt ihr ne ahnung,
so machen wir den gameplay mal aus und game capture an, jawoll sehr schön, auf gehts overwatch
in current year, ja aber echt, ich werde jetzt wieder entspannt im kreis grinden heute, gestern
war doch richtig nicer stream, ich glaube gestern war der längste stream überhaupt,
ich gucke gerade mal nach wie lang das gestern war, 7 stunden, 7 stunden, hast du link mit
deinen pc specs, ich glaube so geht das, nein, so guck mal den chat, nein nein das war das
erste was falsches, zweites ist das richtige, der geizhalslink ist der richtige, also der
hier, ich kanns auch gerade noch mal im, ich zeig es noch mal im stream, weil gibt ja fast
jeden stream irgendwelche fragen zu hardware und sonst was, da kann ich den rechner gerade
noch mal zeigen, wenn wir schon dabei sind bevor es losgeht, außerdem haben wir eh noch
zeit bis es nacht wird und spätestens wenn nacht wird müssen wir umloggen, gibts nämlich
mehr monster exp, die musik könnte ein bisschen lauter sein oder, so, ja aber ich blende mal
browser ein für, weil wir haben doch hier irgendwo, wir machen jetzt einfach window
capture firefox, bam, geht doch, drehen wir das gleich wieder um, ne wir machen nicht
window capture, wir machen, das ist ziemlich doof window capture zu machen, wir machen
nochmal ne neuer window capture, overlay über alles, weil sonst ist das zeug im weg, ok
also ist nochmal für alle disinteressiert, so rechnermäßig den ich mir zusammengestellt
hab vor, wann war das, 2 monaten oder so, irgendwie, in dem dreh, vor 2 monaten, ja,
also hier ist ja auch nur das drinnen was ich mir neu gekauft hab, bis auf die grafikkarte,
also sprich, die alten ssds und sowas sind hier nicht drin, die ich noch vom alten rechner
hatte, so und zwar, ist das jetzt ok vor lautstärke, hintergrund gedudel und so, passt das, das
ist doof, ich muss das jedes mal neu einstellen, weil windows in der meinung ist die sound
nichts zu ändern automatisch, so, rampe also, also was hab ich drin, ich hab ne, als platte
ne ssd drin, ne m2 ssd, die kann man direkt aufs mainboard klippen, braucht man nicht,
ist eigentlich ziemlich überflüssig, aber irgendwie ganz nice, nice to have, irgendwie
ist die musik mir ein bisschen laut, ich glaube ich hab meine settings auch heute anders, moment
das muss ich mal kurz umstellen gerade, wir stellen das jetzt um, hier auf output, jetzt
auf ssd, so ist besser, ne, so, also, kommen wir zuerst, genau, ssd hab ich ja schon erzählt,
ich hab hier den kore i7 8700k, hatte ich mega glück, mal gucken ob das ding mittlerweile
lieferbar ist, ist das irgendwo lieferbar, ja, ja, ok, mittlerweile ist das zeug verfügbar,
ich hab's halt schon seit 2 monaten, das war übertrieben glück, das ich einbekommen
Rgb ram ja bitteschön es muss leuchten easy und es sieht sogar ganz cool aus
Ich habe ein Foto von gemacht
Ich wusste nur meinen eigenen Tweet finden
Ich habe irgendwie geschrieben ram sieht nicht schlecht aus also so sieht der ram dann im endeffekt aus das war als ich auf dem tabi stehen hatte noch das mainboard ich finde das sieht ganz nett aus das leuchtet dann so abwechselnd braucht kein mensch
Danach 1080ti
Weil 1080ti halt dass ich habe tatsächlich die founders edition weil ich habe die schon eine ganze weile und direkt von NVIDIA und dann gibt es halt die founders edition
Kaufen würde ich es mir wahrscheinlich preisleistungsmäßig nicht sondern nur mal kleiner allerdings kriegt man diese grafikkarten generation ganz gut was
Nein ich warte in euer pc das ist immer noch der dann einen z370 mainboard von srock weil bluetooth und 10 gigabit netzwerkkarte on board das einzige mainboard war ziemlich einfach die wahl ultra fetter cpu kühler
Ab ich übrigens muss ich euch auch noch mal zeigen für was man sinnlos geld ausgeben kann
Pass mal auf
Es gibt es gibt für diese noctua aber wie heißt denn der noctua style oder so fuck es gibt es gibt von noctua was wo man seine seine cpu kühler modden kann
Richtig richtig beknackt eigentlich aber ja genau genau das zeug genau das zeug richtig bescheuert ich fand ich habe mir schon lüfter gekauft für 75 euro und jetzt dazu habe ich mir noch mal lüfter cover und einen schwarzen lüfter gekauft mit ich glaube
Ich weiß gar nicht was ich hier für noppen drinne habe ich glaube schwarz oder so und noch so eine abdeckung also sprich ich habe mir noch mal 30 euro ausgegeben oder so einfach dass der lüfter noch stylischer aussieht
Bescheuert ja dabei gucke ich da noch nicht mehr rein so bestes gehäuse überhaupt was es gibt finde ich bestes gehäuse wirklich extrem geiles gehäuse was man jetzt hier nicht sieht ist wie clever das aufgebaut ist was lüfter angeht
Man sieht das hier jetzt nicht richtig airflow da geht es bestimmt diagramm für das ist richtig clever gemacht ja hier sieht man es guck hier sieht man es schön also du hast es in dem gehäuse so hier unten kommt das netzteil rein und du lässt das netzteil von unten ansaugen hier unten im boden sind extra noch mal staubfilter und so füßchen dass es ein bisschen höher ist also sprich von unten wird das angesagt
Hinten raus gepustet das heißt das netzteil ändert überhaupt nichts am airflow im gehäuse hier unten habe ich auch meine platte und die zusätzliche ssds und so noch drinne ja das gehäuse hatten wirklich noch viel mehr kann man alles rausnehmen man sieht es ja hier so sieht es normalerweise aus kann man alles total easy rausnehmen und ich habe vorne 240 mm lüfter drinne und hinten ein das ist jetzt falsch rum was die hier intake das ist blöd
sind das ist das geht hier raus ja also hier kommen die lüfter vorne rein zwei lüfter blasen rein ein lüfter zieht raus das heißt du hast bisschen überdruck im gehäuse weniger staub perfekt
so und halt ein netzteil ein ordentliches ja das habe ich im rechner drin und das ist sehr sehr nice auf gehts logen wir schon mal auf den witztakt um würde ich sagen ja das das marvin finde ich auch finde ich auch ich mag gehäuse die
einfach qualitativ hochwertig sind und was was halt keiner braucht sind irgendwie so wie heißt das gab es von kurs ja glaube ich eins was übelst ja so was hier das sieht halt übelst abgedreht aus brauche man so was ernsthaft ich brauche es nicht das ist wahrscheinlich kein schlechtes gehäuse aber ich finde es total abgedreht
achso man sieht es jetzt gar nicht ne lull ich soll moment das da meine ich das ist halt total abgedreht braucht kein mensch so so gamer gehäuse was es da alles gibt hier gamer case guckt euch das guckt euch das teilweise mal an das ist doch total overkill also es gibt bestimmt leute die finden das hier cool wenn das so alien mäßig aussieht aber ich finde
so diese klassischen gehäuse hier die hochwertig gebaut sind ja und das ist das f5 finde ich viel besser ja vorne zwei schöne lüfter rein gut ist sehen aus wie transformers ja ist echt so
über den rechner spielst und stimmst du gleichzeitig weil mir wurde immer gesagt hol dir zwei rechne und dann kannst du ordentlich streamen und zocken ich streame ich streame und spiele über den gleichzeitig das ist auch überhaupt kein
problem weil ich habe hier meine meine obs settings ich enkode ja mittlerweile sogar mit cpu nicht mit grafikkarte also mal wenn du wenn du quasi den den h264 encoder von der grafikkarte verwendest dann kannst du ohne
probleme spielen und streamen vom gleichen rechner weil das kostet keine cpu leistung der encoder in der grafikkarte der wird ja sonst eh nicht genutzt er ist da also das also auf jeden fall gar kein problem allerdings ist die qualität wenn du cpu encodest höher und allerdings ich habe sogar jetzt hier in streaming settings eingestellt
dass ich streame 720p und habe sogar cpu usage low also das hat also cpu usage preset das kann man einstellen obs auf low das heißt die cpu rechnet richtig für für einzelne frames also du kannst du kannst als presets kann man einstellen quasi ultrafast superfast medium slow und ich hab's auf slow das heißt die cpu lässt sich besonders viel zeit beim rechnen bei einem frame um den frame zu
komp zu komprimieren und macht halt dadurch die bildqualität besser und das ist überhaupt kein problem ich habe jetzt wenn bdo hier im hinter wenn bdo läuft und mit bdo 100 fps in velia im hintergrund habe ich cpu auslastung gucken wir mal cpu auslastung habe ich jetzt gerade 77 prozent das sind 41 prozent bdo und 31 prozent sehe ich jetzt hier gerade sind obs und chrome hat nochmal 2 prozent
wahrscheinlich für die musik im hintergrund also wirklich gar kein ding funktioniert so habe ich irgendwas gesellt heute im marketplace ja erstmal erstmal erstmal geld einsammeln nein nicht das nicht das listings collect zack guck mal paar tage spiel easy 100 millionen gemacht weiß auch
keine ahnung am anfang wo ich wieder anderen gestartet habe nachdem er nachdem der fabian ja wo wo ich mit fabian zusammen war ein komplettes gear was ich gesammelt habe erstmal gerippt habe bis halt auf die auf die ringe habe ich jetzt in den letzten paar tagen obwohl ich nichts gemacht habe im endeffekt einfach 100 millionen das geht in dem game wirklich schnell mal ein bisschen am stück spielt
so locken wir auf den wizard rum bock auf paar runden battlefield 4 ich habe battlefield 4 gar nicht mehr installiert
also man kann ohne problem auf dem gleichen rechner spielen und streamen ich überlege mir ob ich mir so eine so eine neue cap diese neue capture karte von elgato mit den mobs ob ich mir die neue capture karte von elgato hole
oder mal bei elgato frage ich eine kriege weil die nimmt ja 4k auf oder nimmt allerdings auch full ad auf mit 144 oder 120 fps das könnte man machen weil ich habe hier nochmal einen ziemlich guten rechner daneben stehen
oh nice oh mega exp gibt es jetzt ey das ist geil wir haben jetzt eine stunde golden bell xp krass wir haben eine stunde golden bell xp ich habe hier noch black spirit kann man irgendwie black spirit things hier combat xp
combat xp buff noch an dann machen wir gleich noch daily xp an und dann ist noch nacht das geht ab leute easy 80 prozent in der nacht es gibt krass exp habe ich einen pet wir müssen leider heute wieder ein bisschen kreisel kreiten
ich finde das ist eine ganz gute rotation und gibt dick xp vor allem wenn wir jetzt auf dem channel sogar noch golden bell xp anhaben was war das gerade für ein grafik bug
vielleicht gehen wir aber nachher auch nochmal zum anderen spot aber hier mache ich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal die nacht durchgegrindet
ich weiß sehr easy es ist in 30 ingame minuten ist nacht ari magos du checkst das game nicht was gibts also was was was denn genau also mein aktuelles ist wirklich ziemlich simpel ich laufe im kreis mache 3 spells und töte mobs für exp und gelb
da gibt es eigentlich nicht viel zu checken das ist so wie jedes mao du grindest vor dich hin im kreis hier grindest da halt vor dich hin wohin du bei anderen mmo's halt quest nach quest nach quest grind machst was im prinzip eigentlich nicht viel unterschied ist
viele leute sagen ja oh mein gott grind so eine scheiße aber die meisten quests in mmo's sind halt auch einfach sinnloser grind die interessanten quests in mmo's kannst du dir an einer hand abzählen
warum low fof weiß ich weil ich das fof die ganze zeit so hab irgendwie dran gewöhnt weiß ich wir können was ich hab so nie ausprobiert was das fof für auswirkung auf fps hat im game doch ich also ich hat es mal auf dem alten rechner ausprobiert da hatte ich ziemlich schlechte fps mit höherem fof aber wir können es mal ausprobieren
wo geht denn das nochmal hier game screen ne wo kommt man fof umstellen die optionen von dem spiel sind so gestört du findest gar nichts es müsste eigentlich unter screen sein field of view in screen in der mitte
bin ich blind oder seh ich das nicht? ich kann sogar farbenblind modus einstellen okay komm mal ganz langsam
fof adjust vision range okay adjust effect adjust scaling ah hier okay wir sind jetzt auf 50
also wirklich ein fof ist das jetzt ja ah fof 70 macht überhaupt keinen unterschied in fps das ist so klein spielen das nur die pros oder was? das ist mir fast schon zu klein
ich mein klar das ist im prinzip nicht schlecht man sieht halt mehr mit dem ganzen felsen was man nach 56 überhaupt noch machen soll
also mit 56 bist du noch nicht mal halbwegs soweit dass du überhaupt irgendwie endgame mäßig großartig weiter machen kannst du musst erst mal also erst mal auf 58 leveln und die anderen sachen sowas was felsen zu denken an
anbelangt und enchantment bin ich auch der übelste noob ich habe es ja gestern mehrfach gesagt im game ich bin in dem game allgemein der übelste noob enchantment macht der farben ja wer kann das besser ich spiele ja auch selten ich will jetzt erst mal hauptsächlich 60 crime oh jetzt hat es aber geruckelt
ja und seit gestern haben wir auch ein neues gear kommando mit dem aktuellen gear
ne das ist mir ein bisschen klein um ehrlich zu sein also vielleicht mache ich keine 50 fof sondern ich mache so ein zwischending wird das level cap von dem spiel eigentlich mal erhöht es wurde immer wieder angepasst also level cap an sich du hast ja auch schon anführungsstrichen geschrieben gibt es ja an sich nicht
allerdings hast du früher schon verdammt viel zeit gebraucht sagen wir mal für 60 und 61 war echt der mega grind des todes ja die xp kurve haben so ein bisschen angepasst also 60 schaffst du jetzt relativ easy wie man hier oben sieht bei mir von der geschwindigkeit her
übrigens erinnert mich mal dran hier in 22 minuten ist mir dia meal dran sonst vergesse ich das wieder ich vergesse das nämlich immer kennt mich ja mittlerweile ich bin immer buff
das fof ist mir ein bisschen groß muss ich sagen ein bisschen hoch
aber 60 60 ist glaube ich ganz gut ja das ist besser das ist nicht ganz so klein und man sieht ein bisschen mehr
also kann man auch level 1000 werden theoretisch schon praktisch ist bis dahin wahrscheinlich wenn man die xp kurve mal anguckt wahrscheinlich bis dahin das universum existiert nicht mehr bis du level 1000 bist so viel zeit würde das brauchen
also halbwegs realistisch ist 62 und das ist auch schon abartiger grind weiß gar nicht ob es leut was die höchsten leute in korea sind ich glaube 63er gibt es noch aber ich glaube das wars
so jetzt machen wir mal unseren ganzen xp shit an was habe ich denn vorher gesagt daily xp buch buch muss ich nochmal klicken buch spirit ok ich brauche jetzt bloß noch daily xp dann gehts ab zeige ich euch
cookie wo ist mein daily xp da jetzt gehts ab jetzt gehts richtig krass ab und danach muss man nochmal energy waste uns vom black spirit was holen die xp geht ab
richtig krass jawoll ja also wenn es ja genau die koreaner sind 63 also es gibt kein max level du kriegst immer noch xp und das geht hier oben auch immer weiter hoch allerdings ist halt so langsam
das geht nicht realistisch gesehen aber die kurve davor haben sie jetzt schon ein paar mal angepasst und du brauchst auch nicht mehr als level 60 früher gab es noch spells nachlevel
60 also spell upgrades oder ability upgrades nachlevel 60 die wurden jetzt alle auflevel 60 runtergestuft also sprich mitlevel 60 kriegt man seine letzten spells im vergleich zu viel anderen mmos ist sogar bislevel 60 schon krasser monster grind ja sieht man ja hier aber es geht halbwegs und ja genau was ich vorher sagen wollte
warum hast du ja bei anderen mmos oftmals halt den quest grind du startest dann dann dann stehst du für einen trainer npc der trainer npc sagt dir dann sammle 20 plumen dann gehst du 20 plumen sammeln dann sagst du oh das ist toll dass du 20 plumen gesammelt hast geh zu meinem zu meinen kollegen in der nächsten stadt gehst du zur nächsten stadt zum npc und dann sagt oh bitte verteile das abend das abendessen an die truppen klickst du 20 leute an wisst ihr so diese so diese dämlichen questen wo sind die?
wo sind die mobs hier hin?
Moment hier ist einer
die sind schon mal am pissen ey
pissen schalte
warum ist da eine katze?
weil da sonst der chat ist
der ingame chat
und im prinzip machst du in anderen mmos halt auch grind da machst du halt textbox durchklick grind bei quests und minigame zeugs grind
und hier machst du halt spells drücken und monster grind
also auch wenn es im westen übelst verhasst ist so dieses grind grinding level ist das finde ich gar nicht so viel unterschied zu anderen mmos
weil ob du jetzt quests grindest oder monster grindest du grindest halt
irgendwie sieht dein grind richtig langsam aus ja ist ja wahrscheinlich auch
wahrscheinlich weil die schon 3 spells machen und eigentlich überhaupt keine ahnung von dem game up
easy easy drop
gleich mal wieder 25 millionen
na vor allem sieht der grind so langsam aus weil hier keine monster mehr sind
weil hier wieder irgendwelche leute am start sind
easy einfach mal 24 mm
kannst mal dein gear zeigen mach mal ausruhezeichen gear
haben wir seit gestern geupdatet
aber gestern geupdatet
es ruckelt gerade was denn da los
also wenn es jetzt aber auch euch im stream ruckelt das ruckelt
sorry was ich auch nicht managed
haben wir gestern geupdatet
es ruckelt gerade, was denn da los?
also wenn es jetzt aber euch im stream ruckelt, das ruckelt vor allem im spiel auch
und nipples
das emote habe ich aktiviert
du kannst aber rare parrot verwenden
wenn du ein dense emote brauchst
ja, den haben wir am start
ich muss woanders hin, hier sind zu wenig mobs, zu viele leute am start
ja
jeder kann nicht angreifen
allerdings ist es auch nicht so einfach
du kannst jetzt nicht permanent irgendwelche leute schlitzen und schnetzeln
das kannst du theoretisch schon, aber da hast du auch ein paar nachteile durch
sicher, dass es ab 50 ist, wo ein jeder angreifen kann
ich habe irgendwo gelesen, das wurde vor ein paar patches auf 55 erhöht
aber bin ich jetzt nicht einmal sicher, ich glaube 50 war das mal
ich meine 50 ist man ja heutzutage easy, instant quasi fast schon
wir kriegen gerade eggs, wie sauer, das ist nice
golden bell exp, black spirit exp, daily exp, exp tea, nacht exp
volle explodung
ja, und die spells sehen normalerweise ein bisschen anders aus
die sind nicht so durchsichtig und der bildschirm wackelt auch
ich habe übrigens keinen in-game sound, fällt mir gerade einer
ihr solltet ja nicht aufgefallen, dass ich keinen in-game sound habe
ich mache mal in-game sound an
wartet mal
etf
kannst du keine stärkeren mobs farm, doch
aber man muss das ja immer balancen, so killspeed zu mobsstärke
was es für xp für gibt
und nachdem ich wie gesagt von dem game keine ahnung habe
ich habe den fabian gefragt, was meinst du hier, expo sagt der nagaas wurde genervt, beste exp
das ist ganz entspannt ohne sound
ich kann, wenn ihr wollt, kann ich den sound auch wieder ausmachen
aber so ein bisschen game sound finde ich nicht verkehrt, da hörst du nichts, was passiert
g 1000, nein
zu hause gehe ich nicht
zu hause war ich, wo ich letztes mal gespielt habe, recht oft
das ist ein richtig dummer spot
vor allem überrand ohne ende überall
ein bisschen haftbefehl, ne heut net
du musst dafür das spiel monatlich zahlen, ne, du musst es einmal kaufen und dann kannst du es spielen
es bieten sich allerdings ein paar microtransactions an, sich noch zusätzlich zu holen
also inventarplätze, storageplätze und ein paar pets und sowas
spielerweiterung
das ist nicht, man braucht es nicht unbedingt, also du musst dir das jetzt nicht kaufen
weil man sonst nicht auskommt, aber das ist schon zu empfehlen
ist 60 bis 2018 drin, klar easy, guck mal, wir haben jetzt gleich 80
wir haben jetzt gleich 80, bis die nacht fertig ist hoffe ich mal
weil es jetzt ein fett exp gibt hier mit buff und guck mal wie schnell das geht hier
ich mach das platt, was gibt denn hier so ein pack
das war jetzt 2,5 pack, müssen wir mal kurz gucken, was gibt denn so ein pack
30 oder so, 25, 30
doch, geil, btf, wie es geruckelt hat
der denkt hier kann man eine mob spaschen oder was
so geht es nicht
du siehst keinen fortschreitenden exp, guck doch mal oben links
sieht man doch, bei jedem pack sind es so 10-15% bei einem größeren pack
25, 30, jetzt haben wir 406
und nach dem pack haben wir 422, 424 easy
und das geht schnell gerade, das geht schnell
das geht schnell, wir haben zig exp buffs an, 200% daily exp
20% black spirit exp, nacht exp, golden bell exp, wir haben alles
normalerweise ist das noch so, ist das langsam
und das ist immer noch schneller als vor ein paar patches
vor ein paar patches waren 59, 60, das hat ewig gedauert gefühlt
und lass mal 60, 60, 61.000 vor, der farben hat glaube ich ein paar monate gegrindet
bis er 61 war, dauert das nicht ewig, ne mittlerweile nicht mehr
mittlerweile nicht mehr, was ist max level, gibt es nicht
realistisch erreichbar sagen wir mal 62, aber da musst du schon monate grinden für
also die exp kurve bis 60 ist mittlerweile ganz ok, 60 packt jeder
mit ein bisschen ausdauer, also sogar ich, ich spiele das game ja quasi kaum
sogar ich bin demnächst 60, aber alles da drüber ist sehr sehr harter grind
man braucht es aber auch nicht wirklich
die letzten spell upgrades gibt es mit 60 jetzt auf allen klassen, zwar früher nicht so
und fallen die nicht um
wieviel exp brauchen wir von 60 auf 61 keine ahnung
muss man mal in irgendeine exp label gucken, an der stelle ruckelt es heute
an der stelle hat es gestern nicht geruckelt
ja was ich noch sagen wollte, die zauber sehen normalerweise nicht so durchsichtig aus
und das build shake auch mehr und der wizard schreit rum und sowas, das habe ich alles ausgeschaltet
also wenn ihr das neu installieren solltet, sieht es bei euch ein bisschen anders aus
ich habe die spells aber halb durchsichtig gemacht
das gewackel ausgeschaltet und das schreien vom wizard ausgeschaltet weil mich das genervt hat
inf ist voll, müssen wir jetzt deleteen, wir können jetzt nicht zurück
wir müssen die nachts auscryten komplett
oder ist der weg das ziel, ja je nachdem was man sieht, man kann auch, selbst wenn man ausgelevelt hat
kann man immer noch saumäßig viel machen oder eigentlich geht es ja lange erst richtig los
vor allem wenn man auf pvp steht, du hast ja 4-5 verschiedene arten wie du hier pvp betreiben kannst
entweder du kannst open world pvp machen, also du kannst theoretisch jeden angreifen
du kannst einen auf bandit in der wüste machen, du kannst in die arena gehen, du kannst battlefield machen
du kannst skillbelagerungen machen, du kannst allerdings auch einen auf den übelsten crafter machen
und farmen und fischen, du kannst beispielsweise den schiff craften, kaufen oder was auch immer
dann kannst du hier oben, das habe ich noch nie gemacht, kannst du hier aufs meer als krasser fischer fahren
suchst dir einen schönen fischspot und fisch dir dann da halt einen ab
also selbst für crafter hat das was, es gibt, also das ist nicht alles, es gibt ja noch viel
du kannst alchemie machen, du kannst jagen, du kannst irgendwelche edelsteine herstelle, tränke herstellen
alles mögliche zeug, also wenn man da drauf steht hat man da auch viel zu tun
dann kann man noch, moment erst mal das pack weg machen
dann kann man sich noch stundenlang hier mit beschäftigen quasi wie man hier seine punkte investiert
in unterschiedliche notes, also sprich da kann man zum beispiel, wenn man die karte aufgedeckt hat
kann man dann hier, wo habe ich denn hier was, wo ist ein velier, da oben, so, da kann man beispielsweise hier hingehen
und sich unterkünfte für arbeiter mieten an dieser farm und die bauen dann kartoffel ab und hähnchen an und sonst was
und da kriegt man dann wieder materiale, die man für andere sachen verwenden kann
und mit diesem worker system kann man sich auch stundenlang, tage, monate lang beschäftigen
die richtigen notes, was man braucht, die richtige kombination, die richtigen worker, die da arbeiten
es gibt worker auch in verschiedenen, das ist jetzt kein gutes beispiel, weil das ist shit
es gibt verschiedene worker rassen, die sachen unterschiedlich schnell können, verschiedene levels für die worker und was auch immer
also da kann man sich wirklich monatelang mit beschäftigen, wenn man das will
woher hast du das geld für dein gear bekommen, ich hab gelevelled
ich hab gelevelled und hab immer schön daily rewards abgeholt
und dann haben wir das meiste aus dem auktionshaus gesniped
und ich überleg grad welches gear habe ich denn nicht aus dem auktionshaus
genau, die rüstung hab ich aus einer daily reward kiste
und die schuhe hab ich übertriebenes glück gehabt, hab ich aus der questrolle bekommen
allerdings arbeiten die worker nicht umsonst, die worker brauchen bier
du musst quasi immer regelmäßig in die map gehen und deine arbeiter mit bier versorgen
und bier stellst du quasi auch wieder mit worker her
da musst du kartoffel abbauen und das ist auch der grund warum ich hier als wizard in diesem kochkostüm rumlaufe
dass es so komisch ausschaut, das ist dass ich besser bier craften kann
und weil es mehr xp gibt nochmal, hat auch xp bonus drauf
so ich schmeiß jetzt mal die hälfte von meinem zeug hier weg
ich kann jetzt nicht zurück in die stadt, ich muss grinden
die nacht geht noch 4 stunden
bringt die normale waffe überhaupt noch was, wenn man sowieso immer nur die awakening benutzt
ja, ich kann dir nicht genau sagen wie es sich berechnet
ich weiß nur dass es eingerechnet wird
die wird in den char mit eingerechnet die normale waffe, also es ist wichtig dass du eine gute normale waffe hast
also eine gute non awakening waffe
sehr wichtig
ich geh jetzt mal in die andere richtung, hier ist mir zu viel los gerade
also das heißt umso besser deine normale waffe ist, umso mehr schaden machst du auch mit den awakening spells
hier ist es ja total überrannt an spots, das ist ja wahnsinn ey, was ist denn hier los
hier ist ja mal total, moment wo laufen die oberplanken, wo gehts denn jetzt lang da, da kann man splashen
aber hier ist auch xp buff gerade aktiv auf dem server, deswegen sind alle hier am start
ne ich pvp hier jetzt keinen, das dauert dann ewig und dann ist ganze zeit verschwendet zum xp
an wie genau sich das rechnet kann ich euch nicht sagen, aber es wird auf jeden fall mit eingerechnet was eure normale waffe
also das ding hier, der starb, was der für werte hat wird in euren awakening damage mit eingerechnet
das sind eindeutig zu viele leute, wir können uns auch nicht channel switchen
wer ist so richtig wie bdo starten nach 16 oder wieder semi afk
ich spiele das spiel ja im endeffekt habe ich ja angefangen schon letztes jahr glaube ich
ich spiele das immer nur kurz und danach hole ich daily rewards ab und grind immer ab und zu mit dem fabian irgendwas
also ich spiele ja gar nicht viel, selbst daran sieht man, dass wenn man das halbwegs anstrengt, dann kriegt man da als größte loop was hin
ich habe ja nichts im vergleich zum fabian als spielzeit, alles kaputt ey
so viele schmups, so viele schmups am start, buff food, jawoll, bam, thx
sag doch die nacht kriegen wir easy 80, brauche ich black spirit buff wieder, ja brauche black spirit buff
falls man den mehrfach am tag aktivieren darf habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
aber der frisich hat mir alles entschadet, ja richtig, der fabian ist der mit game knowledge hier, wie gesagt habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung
ich kann ein bisschen mein wizard in kreise grind mäßig spielen aber das war's, was mit den mobs los, haben die irgendwie, sind die ein bisschen desyncht
naja, dann desyncht, sehr schön, ja psychologicaler, siehst du was, ich hab kaum was gemacht in dem game
also bezüglich contribution points in energy kann man auch viel mehr machen, das habe ich nicht viel
das macht wahrscheinlich jemand, der sich richtig gut in dem game auskennt, innerhalb von einem tag, wenn er die besten wege kennt, wie man da läuft mit einem neuen account machen sollte
mobs bashen
der wizard grind ist immer noch real, der wizard grind wird auch real bleiben bis ich 60 bin, ich mach das jetzt jeden tag, ich grind jetzt jeden tag bis ich 60 bin
ja, haben wir locker, locker in 25 minuten haben wir locker 80%
ja mach ich, ich hab sogar schon was aufgenommen, schon vor einer weile
was ist eine gute allrounder klasse, ich find wizard ist top
wizard find ich super, wizard kannst du eigentlich fast alles machen
also du kannst ja prinzipiell, in dem game ist es ja gar nicht so schlimm, dass es klassen gibt, mit denen du gar nichts selber machen kannst
aber ich find wizard gut, wizard ist easy zu leveln, du brauchst keine heiltränke und sonst nichts großartiges
großartig gierabhängig bist du auch nicht zum leveln
und wizard kannst du halt auch super farmen, und wenn du dann was anderes spielen willst, kannst du wizard immer noch als bossheld verwenden, den du einfach da abstellst und umlocksst, wenn es einen boss zu killen gibt
hast du overwatch jetzt komplett geraged, ich hab gestern ja nochmal gespielt
da will er wegrennen
zu wenig mobs, slick dumb xp buff, alle wollen sie hier leveln
ja flocks, mit wizard kannst du alles machen
sogar letztens mal irgendwo gesehen, dass wizard angeblich auch einen one on one turnier gewonnen hat, ausgerechnet wizard ja
irgendwo ist mal ein pattern
7, warum sind alle mobs weg, sollen sich mal verpissen
kann man den wizard auch komplett mit feuer spielen, nee
also wenn du den nur komplett mit feuer spielst, dann hast du zu wenig spells
wizard spells die awakening skills bestehen halt aus wasser und feuer
du hast hier diesen frontalen feuer e, du hast hier diesen point blank feuer e und du hast halt diesen komet, dann kannst du noch gegner dir schnappen oder auf den boden werfen, das ist auch ein feuer spell, du hast ein feuer pet und du hast halt auch ein wasser pet, was ich nie verwende
wasser grill pet, das feuer pet ist nahe kampf und das andere pet ist alt range, wer hätte das gedacht
ich muss hier mal weg, viel zu viel los
wie findest du mystic, ich finde striker irgendwie ist gar nicht so meins und mystic ist ja quasi so
striker 2.0 plus als grill
die einzige nahe kampf klasse in dem game die mir gefällt ist bersi, am anfang habe ich ja bersi gespielt, also damals letztes jahr als wir da angefangen haben
meine frage wenn man den life skill handelt auf oni da fragst du den falschen
ob man dann mehr geld keine ahnung da fragst du den falschen
da kann ich dir nichts zu sagen
gild wars 2, gild wars 2 haben wir auch gespielt, gild wars 2 fand ich einfach kacke
wahrscheinlich weil wir es, also ich habe gild wars 2 ja auch erst gespielt als ich schon ein bisschen draußen war, es hat mir gar nicht gefallen
ich habe noch nie so ein langweiliges rumgerenne und gequestet, bzw. war noch nicht mal quests in gild wars 2
man rennt über die maps und füllt herzchen auf, also gild wars 2 hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen, gar nicht
das ist mit den addons jetzt ein bisschen besser habe ich gelesen, aber nä nä nä
bisschen crime ist nicht verkehrt, außerdem der hauptgrund warum ich bdo spiele ist ja weil der fabian bdo spielt
dass wir mal wieder ein bisschen was zusammenspielen können mmo technisches
so voll und mein rucksack ist auch voll
ein bisschen was aus dem rucksack rausschmeißen
wenn die nacht vorbei ist und wir 80 prozent haben gehen wir in die stadt den kram abgeben
es kommen 2018 ein paar neue mmo rauss
vielleicht gefällt euch ja das, vielleicht gefällt euch da ja was von, gibt ja dieses mmo von den pupke erstellen
oh nee hör mal auf
da hat die welt beim besten willen nicht drauf gewartet auf dieses mmo
das nächste mmo dem ich was zutraue falls es überhaupt rauskommen sollte
man die wollten ja schon irgendwie sind eineinhalb jahre in der beta sein ist camelot unchained
allerdings weiß man halt da nicht bescheid ob es denn mal rauskommt oder nicht
was war in lost ark noch mal war das dieses asia diablo style game
so wird das mit 80 prozent aber nix
ich geh jetzt mal hier vorne links
nee das hat mir nicht so gut gefallen
das war ja auch mehr hack and slay so wie es ausgesehen hat
keine ahnung es hat mir nicht so gefallen vom ersten eindruck was ich so gesehen habe
was bei mmos halt so ist oder was nicht nur bei mmos was halt bei vielen spielen so ist
dass da halt im vorfeld immer so viel erzählt wird was der tag lang wenn der tag lang ist
wir haben das innovativste level system das innovativste loot system das innovativste
event system die besten rates den besten group content die besten items so bla bla bla
bla bla ja und am endeffekt kochen sie auch alle nur mit wasser
der plus nein hör mal auf plus ja das kenne ich das habe ich nicht gespielt aber das kenne
ich das das fällt auch eindeutig so unter kack mmos moment wo bin ich jetzt hier lang
wo bin ich hierhin gelaufen
der frasier ist am start
Fabian siehst du hier oben links 80 prozent gleich easy clap
habe ich eigentlich tagestiel fast schon erfüllt innerhalb von zehn minuten
der wizard ist real
der kreisel klein ist real
und mit 60 kriegst du noch mal spell upgrades und mach noch mehr da mage
ich mache ja noch eindeutig zu wenig schaden wenn man sie da muss noch mehr
ich gucke mal was es da unten gibt zum zum basten weil da oben ist einfach viel zu viele
typen die mobs basten
ist aber auch nichts
ist hier nichts mehr das ist ja kacke wo gibt es denn hier noch mobs da oben ist überfüllt mit spielern
hier unten ist nichts mehr
Fabian vielleicht weißt du das ich habe irgendwo gesehen es gibt jetzt
es soll jetzt wohl irgendwie level rewards oder sowas geben
also sprich wenn du levels kriegst du wohl schmuck der auf dem niveau sein muss von von ultra teuren enchanted schmuck
weißt du da irgendwas oder ist das erst in korea
nach 61 und 62 ok das reden wir 2020 da mal drüber
übrigens was lustiges wenn man hier hoch guckt heller tag aber angeblich ist es 6.30 morgens und ist noch nacht
Fabian wollen wir heute irgendwas grinden oder erst am Wochenende
am Wochenende
also bis zum Wochenende bin ich wahrscheinlich sogar 60 oder kurz kurz vor 60
also mit Wochenende xp buff ist er dann easy mode angesagt
Mr. Cotswores das ist scheiße Mr. Cotswores sagt Mr. Vorgors
es gibt jetzt für solche fälle gibt es jetzt ein kotz und wirk emoji ist jetzt neu
unicode 7 und 8 da haben sie sich endlich mal was bei gedacht
dann gehen das hier noch 13 minuten
witch level was du willst witch level hast du nicht mal gesagt du willst nie wieder witch spielen weil es so langweilig
genau das Serious Works hat es gefunden kotz emoji
ist hier irgendwas doch da oben sind noch mobs hier sind so viele leute
alle wegen diesem komischen xp buff habt ihr am Anfang gesehen dass dieser xp buff noch nicht an war oder gerade aktiv geworden ist aber keine sauter
also mir macht wizard zu leveln bock das ist so schön praying afk kannst du den chat gucken und drückst 3 spells ich meine ich habe hier 20 spells oder so aber ich brauche halt nur 3
wizard ist genau die richtige klasse für mich übrigens ich spiele ja auch nur wizard müsst ihr mal wissen
ich spiele ja eigentlich auch nur wizard weil der Fabian gemeint hat wizard ist bestimmt das richtige und wizards beste
wizards genauer das richtige einfach 3 spells drücken alles own und profit easy win easy life
was ist das Ziel hier im Spiel das hängt so ein bisschen von dir ab was du machen willst also ich weiß es ist immer eine ziemlich doofere Antwort im Prinzip ist das Spiel natürlich wie in den
meisten MMOs Charakterleveln und besseres Skill kriegen so mal aus hause unterm Strich ja
allerdings kannst du ja auch so viele Sachen machen die einen spielen das eher so als Wirtschaftssimulator die anderen spielen das für PvP Bash andere machen den ganzen Tag irgendwelche
Crafting, Farming, Fishing Geschichten andere grinden einfach im Kreis weil es ihnen Spaß macht du kannst es relativ vielfältig was du machen kannst deswegen hängt es auch ein bisschen von dir ab was du machen willst
also wenn du der geilste Farmer der Welt werden willst der geilste Gatherer, Hunter, Fischer oder sonst was kannst du das machen kannst aber auch dich gieren und in irgendeine PvP Gilde gehen und andere Gilden
halt begriegen kannst du alles mögliche machen
die frage was einem da gefällt ich werde jetzt erstmal 60 machen ich bin immer ich spiele spiele ein übelst casual mäßig und relativ selten ich habe jetzt drei Monate oder so immer gespielt
aber was die wirklich ganz gut hingekriegt haben du hast hier als 24 7 Sucht Typ hast du schon deine Vorteile aber du wirst nicht total abgehängt
das kann man jetzt gut und schlecht finden das sind alles seine Vor- und Nachteile aber für mich ist es natürlich nicht schlecht
ich habe 80% die GEs ich schmeiß noch mal ein bisschen Loot weg ich will nämlich noch die Golden Bell XP ausnutzen für ein paar Minuten natürlich habe ich meinen Gaul sonst wo stehen lassen
Übrigens Fabian bist noch da weißt du was gestern getroppt ist
Ja zwei Setups sind gestern auch getroppt also heute ist einer und einer gestern ne aber weißt du was gestern noch getroppt ist
da kommst du nicht drauf ich habe mir sagen lassen es ist übel selten ich weiß zwar nicht was man damit machen soll
ein wie hieß denn das Ding Black Magic Crystal die Black Magic Power Crystal oder irgendwie sowas
im Chat meinte jemand das wäre seltenstes Item im Game keine Ahnung ob das stimmt
hier oben ist ein ganz netter Spot fällt mir da gerade so auf warum bin ich hier noch nie gewesen
hier oben ist ja noch mehr das ist ja nice was bringt das jetzt was meinst du Twist 96
wie findest du deine Mystik ist das ein Hottest Mystiker Grill
mit Flügel sehr dünn begleitet will ich die hat ja quasi nichts an
das krasse item was getroppt ist das ist irgend so ein item was du benutzen kannst du bist quasi defense mäßig fast unsterblich für eine halbe Stunde
ich weiß aber auch nicht so genau wozu man das braucht höchstens halt wenn man wenn man gilden pvp macht oder sowas
Fogans Alter ja Fogans könnte ich nachher echt mal wieder gehen hätte ich sogar bock drauf Fogans beste sehe ich auch so
was ich an dem Spot hier halt gut finde ist dass du direkt um die Ecke in storage und Händler hast Fogans müsste ich mir irgendwie eine Villa holen oder sowas
der Fräser kleines Fützchen
hier lang
fünf nach fünf Minuten
80% easy sagt auch nach der Nacht haben 80%
und ganz richtig ich muss mir jetzt erstmal gleich Sushi bestellen und da muss man uns anstrengend überlegen was weil ich bin da immer sehr unkreativ
Fabian weiß noch wo ich gesagt habe Sushi ist nichts für mich nie froher Fisch nie will ich net
ja ich mach gleich die Seite auf da kann man gucken
also ich will irgendwie bisschen was gemischtes ich will irgendwelche Rolls mit Sesam drauf also Fisch und Sesamdinger und Seaweed und Zeug drum herum
und dann will ich irgendwie noch was mit Lachs keine Ahnung was vergleichbar gucken ich will irgendwas gemischtes ich will irgendwie so eine Platte haben
hier gehts dann weiter Sushi beste ja
ich hab keine Ahnung wo ich bin ich glaub hier gehts zurück zum Bazar
hier unten ist der
wir rushen jetzt hier einfach nochmal durch
Pekan gegen den afk Typ und dann gehen wir zurück zum Bazar und geben Items ab und noch Sackengold ein und dann könnte man echt mal ne Runde Fogens stellsen
ich hab gestern schon den ganzen Tag Naga gestellt ich hab eigentlich gar keinen Bock auf weitere Naga Kreisel eventuell komm ich doch eh das wär geil dann gehen wir auf Fogens zu zweit Fogens Alter
Fogens Swift Rage Fogens Beste aber Fogens Beste dann aber vorher muss ich Sushi bestellen
aber halt ohne voice achja klar kann man einfach kreiseln
ich nehm eine Bento Box ist Bento nicht nur die Art und Weise wie das verpackt ist oder halt wie die Schüssel aussieht oder halt dieser Pack
Golden Bell ist fertig easy haben wir perfekt ausgenutzt jetzt haben wir quasi 1,8% das sind noch 19% das ist easy bis Silvester drinnen
aber wenn wir im Bazar sind muss ich Sushi bestellen ich hab übelst Hunger
aber vorher muss ich mein Browser gucken dass ich hier nicht meine Adresse leake ich glaub vom Streaming Account hab ich noch nie was bestellt
so gehts hier zurück ja ich glaub hier gehts zurück so also falls ich irgendwelche Sachen überlesen hab im Chat ich guck grad nochmal rein ich war ja sehr aufs Grinden fokussiert
ne Black Magic Capture Card ist getroppt Serious Max was meinst du haben die neue angekündigt oder was meintest du damit
weil ich hatte ja früher immer ne Black Magic Karte und ich muss ehrlich sagen so vom Gerät an sich hat die mir besser gefallen als die von Elgato
oder was zum einbauen war von dieser neuen von Elgato kann ich noch gar nichts sagen
sonst noch irgendwas überlesen kann man bei den Nagas Quests annehmen für Nagas ähm bei Nagas weiß ich gar nicht also es gibt einmalige Quests ich weiß nicht ob es Daily Nagabash Quests gibt beim Fogan gibt es sowas glaube ich
ich hab nichts verpasst blimp blimp blimp Offer Watch?
achso Serious Max jetzt hab ich das verstanden so jetzt müssen wir erstmal Sushi bestellen so verkaufen wir hier den Kram IRL Sushi nicht in game das ist ja immer nicht so klar wenn man das hier so sagt
Rappen äh verkaufen easy money jawoll
Fabian weißt du ob es die Möglichkeit gibt dass die Pets quasi Kristalle und Zeug aufsammeln aber kein schweres Cell Loot weil dann könnte ich bei Fogans ewig rumkraten bis meine Items kaputt sind und krieg trotzdem die besten Sachen und muss nicht permanent wegschmeißen weil Villa kann ich mir nicht holen hab ich ja zu wenig Geld hier
so jetzt muss ich erstmal was zuerst bestellen ganz essentiell wichtig
wir haben zur Auswahl achso ich sollte vielleicht mal den Browser einplanten stimmt ich reite einfach mit dem Pferd hin ja ich bin auch bescheuert ich hab hier meinen Gaul zwar hier stehen lassen aber das Kamel kann ich einfach nehmen
ich nehm einfach das Kamel mit easy reiten wir einfach mit dem Kamel klar hin so Winner Capture BAM
also jetzt was bestelle ich mir denn da jetzt also die haben was ganz nice ist äh Fabian ich bestelle jetzt erstmal Futter also in den nächsten 20 Minuten bin ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht ready da irgendwie zu Fogans zu stellen also alles ganz ruhig
also was ganz gut ist bei denen ist die Sushi Platten sowas hier zum Beispiel Box für zwei Personen und das pack ich easy das ist überhaupt kein Ding aber wir können ja mal gucken was die sonst so haben ist das Letztbestell ja
eigentlich 20 Minuten Essen bestellen aber erstmal jetzt hier aussuchen dann Essen bestellen da musst du noch hoch reiten da muss ich noch zu Fogans reiten das dauert ja eh noch eine Weile
so was nehm ich ja beliebte Gerichte beliebte Gerichte ist große Box dreimal diese diese nicht rollen Dinger mit Lachs Kanäle und Thunfisch Thunfisch mag ich nicht fällt schon mal raus hab ich keinen Bock drauf also ich bestelle mir auf jeden Fall schon mal Rolls Rolls will ich haben
ich will jetzt nicht meine Postleitzahl eintragen ähm California Rolls Thunfisch was nehm ich denn da ich glaube ich glaube ich hol mir ja ich hol mir Rolls mit Kanälen das ist nice das sind nämlich immer vier Stück
so ich will eine Postleitzahl hier auch von der Gegend eingegeben ähm ich will mir ich bestell mir Rollen mit Kanälen das ist nice und dann bestellen wir uns noch ne Box easy fertig reicht
zwei Boxen aber ich weiß was ich mach ich weiß was ich mach ich bestell mir eine ich bestell mir eine Maki Box und dann bestell ich mir noch eine Lachs Box
BÄM 20 Euro easy so das bestell ich mir jetzt ob das reicht ja das reicht das muss reichen mit welchem Bot bot ist du Viewer ja das ist leider Stream Geheimnis
Youtube nennt sich der ähm man könnte allerdings auch eine kleine Box nehmen anstatt der Maki Box dann gibts noch ein paar Rollen dabei weil ich mein so viel Makis braucht man ja eigentlich nicht
das reicht das reicht das ist genug ok ich will mal kurz auf das bestellen nicht auf Klo
und dann bin ich gleich wieder am Start gibt es Dance Emotes gibt es aber das muss man machen gibt es bestimmt noch irgendwelche krassen Dance Emotes wie macht man überhaupt noch mal Emotes in dem Game Dance Dance Emotes
gibt es sowas hier jawoll so er darf jetzt mal seine krassen Emotes machen nichts klar es gibt Dance Emotes ich weiß so nicht wo habe ich mal gesehen irgendwie es gibt Dance Emotes
ich mein guck mal ein Game was zur Hälfte aus Krill Chars besteht da muss es Dance Emotes geben weil ich mein es wird ja von Typen gespielt
so ich bin mal kurz Essen bestellen gleich wieder am Start
ich bin mal kurz Essen bestellen gleich wieder am Start
so wieder am Start
noch nicht mal sowas wie eine Brille ist in BDO ohne irgendeinen Effekt
man muss grind keine Zeit zum Dance es gibt nen Dance Emote ich hab das mal in irgendeinem Video gesehen
ich bin mal kurz Essen bestellen gleich wieder am Start
wie schön die Bäume hier einploppen
floxig bester Stuhl sedus mister 24 Leitwartenstuhl
bester
sedus mister 24 Leitwartenstuhl floxig bester